une nouvelle qui a déjà fait couler de
l'encre qui a fait beaucoup réagir aussi
c'est que la prochaine COP la cop28 qui
se tient à Dubaï sera présidé par un PDG
d'une compagnie pétrolière le sultan
algébab il est aussi ministre de
l'Industrie dans ce pays-là on se tourne
vers Patrick bonnet de Greenpeace Canada
pour en parler justement bonjour
monsieur Bonin bon début d'année à vous
en 2023 dites-nous
bon puisque ça se déroule aux Émirats
arabes unises vous surpris que ce soit
quelqu'un du pétrole qui soit nommé à la
Présidence de l'événement
pas nécessairement surpris par contre
évidemment à l'armée je dirais même
profondément l'armée parce que ce sont
les négociations mondiales sur le climat
ça a été un dangereux précédent qu'on
voit actuellement ça menace évidemment
la crédibilité des immigrés à Unis qui
se sont vu confier la confiance des
Nations Unies là pour diriger cette
importante conférence ou non seulement
pour la transition immédiate mais aussi
pour les générations futures donc c'est
c'est pour nous très inquiétant ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui bon si je dis pour
ça défense il est apparemment aussi un
propriétaire d'une compagnie en énergie
renouvelable est-ce que ça nous met pas
un moins un pied dans la porte avec un
candidat comme lui
malheureusement non parce que le
principal objectif de cette entreprise
nationale de pétrole des émirats c'est
d'augmenter sa production pétrolière de
manière significative d'ici 2030 et on
l'a vu dans le passé le lobbying le
lobbyisme fait par les pétrolières les
gardiens on dilué les négociations
internationales maintenant il aura le
rôle le plus important dans cette
conférence là alors qu'on doit sortir du
pétrole et du gaz et souvenez-vous dans
la dernière conférence les lobby
pétroliers étaient non seulement très
présent ma réussit à faire retirer les
mots pétrole et gaz des négociations
alors qu'on sait que c'est le problème
principal donc on aura droit évidemment
à des lignes de communication comme vous
venez de le mentionner de la part des
Émirats arabes unis qui mettront en
évidence le virage qui veulent faire
alors que dans les faits il continue
quand même dans le pétrole et voit le
pétrole et le gaz comme faisant partie
de la transition alors qu'il faut en
sortir le plus rapidement possible mais
quand on regarde ça je me dis au-delà de
ça que les Nations Unies et confiée la
présidence de l'événement à aux Émirats
arabes ça nous j'ai envie de dire ça
nous en dit presque encore plus long
c'est l'ensemble des nations donc qui
participent à ces nominations là ces
choix là il y a quelqu'un qui a voté
pour donner ça aux Émirats arabes
évidemment les pays font les
propositions ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on a un pays pétrolier le Qatar
par exemple a fait également vous avez
la Pologne ou le lobby du charbon était
très présent ça fait partie de la
dynamique des Nations Unies que toutes
les voies au chapitre soient présents et
les pays riches qui ont les capacités
d'accueillir ce genre de conférence ils
attendent près de 80 000 personnes
évidemment un avantage logistique mais
ce qui est très inquiétant c'est de voir
qui a été mis là si les Émirats arabes
unis avaient un plan crédible pour faire
la transition peut-être qu'il serait
plus crédible lorsqu'il parle de
transition verte mais actuellement on a
la conférence là 2028 c'est la
conférence où faut faire le point comme
prévu dans la corde de Paris où on en
est dans l'état des négociations les
pays doivent s'engager à réduire
davantage leur émission de gaz à effet
de serre mais les Émirats arabes unis
qu'il propose c'est c'est loin de ce que
la science exige une réduction de 50%
les émissions d'ici 2030 c'est ce que la
science demande et les Émirats arabes
unis proposent de ne presque pas réduire
leurs émissions d'ici 2030 donc le
contexte est très inquiétant mais
qu'est-ce que vous suggérez qu'il arrive
maintenant à quoi on lui demande de
démissionner ce qui pourrait être
remplacé ce qu'on pourrait tenir la
conférence ailleurs
écoutez on verra mais lorsqu'il y a une
nomination de ce genre c'est évidemment
extrêmement difficile d'inverser la
tendance et ce sur quoi il faut compter
selon moi c'est clairement d'avoir les
autres pays dont par exemple le Canada
qui est un producteur pétrolier mais qui
devra arriver avec beaucoup plus
d'ambition avec également l'intention
d'influencer la présidence des Émirats
arabes unis donc d'avoir un vrai
leadership entre autres des autres pays
pétroliers ce qu'on a pas vu dans le
passé malheureusement et évidemment ce
sera la société civile également qui se
mobilisera un petit peu partout sur la
planète pour mettre de la pression sur
le pays et les pays en développement
ceux qui sont le plus frappés par les
changements climatiques par les
événements extrêmes qui devront tenir
leur goût comme ils l'ont fait lors de
la récente conférence en Egypte la
dernière conférence des Nations unies on
a vu les pays en développement mais
l'Europe également poussé pour plus
d'ambition on a eu des résultats très
décevants parce que le lobbyisme
pétrolier a réussi à diluer la
conférence mais on a en quelque sorte
sauver les meubles cette mobilisation de
la part des États et pays plus
progressif et de la société civile et
c'est ce que ça prendra clairement bon
mais vous avez un peu fixé notre agenda
pour les prochains mois quand on va
suivre ça en se préparant et en allant
vers cette date-là merci Monsieur bonnet
au plaisir bonne journée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI